i have a question when creating mad
about you um you pulled from your real
life
so it's the only thing i do think about
that though because you've been married
for is it 30 something years
yes 33 years my wife has no idea what i
do professionally so
the less i keep her away when the show
was on i would walk her around the house
and
no um no she was great she was actually
instrumental in in finding helen hunt
we went to a my wife
and helen had a mutual friend and they
had a dinner party and this was just
when i was writing
the the first episode yeah and was
thinking
you know i really didn't know who it
would who i had no actress in mind
and met helen and she was just funny and
smart and just you know just kooky
enough and
and off balance enough and she and we le
and smart and
we left and i said to my wife i said
what do you think about her as you
she went she'd be great so so she was
she got a
she got to say yeah oh yes i would i
wouldn't i wouldn't have cast somebody
like
if my wife said oh i hate that person
but you know the great thing was we had
so many great writers on the show and we
all sit in the room and we'd all
share our stories of what happened at
home that night
so if anything is too personal i could
always go that was the other guy's wife
you would never have said that that's
what songwriters do
right by the way when you're in a
relationship
why people are gonna think i'm like oh
that was the other writer yes on this
song
yeah yeah throw someone else under the
bus
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure